anyone else hungry
i am cooking this ginormous three
inch thick cowboy steak coated in gold
flakes
all right this is how we're going to
start cooking it we're going to head
into the oven we are doing a reverse
sear what that means is we're going to
cook it in the oven first then we're
going to hit it in the pan
to then sear the outsides just to finish
it to get that nice crust so i have my
oven preheated to 300 degrees fahrenheit
we want to cook it until the internal
temperature is between 125
and 130 degrees fahrenheit over here i
have a cast iron skillet
it is screaming hot we already cooked it
all we need to do is sear the outside
to get a nice crust so i'm going to add
in my oil it's ready and
bam first side is in now already it
should be ready to flip
and oh look at that beautiful sear
now we're gonna steer it again for about
45 seconds on this side now we're going
to place this here
for about three to five minutes we have
the gold right over here and now
i am just going to place it
careful oh no that didn't work okay oh
look at that i have now successfully
coated the steak in gold
oh it looks so even nice medium a little
bit
of salt bay action okay let's now give
this a try
my little gold-plated piece of steak
cheers
i feel like i'm not fancied up deep it's
like i feel like this thing like cardiff
you would eat
all right
i made up this black bean burger recipe
in quarantine and i've been obsessed
i'm not vegetarian so i see veggie
burgers as another way to enjoy
vegetables
rather than a meat substitute start off
sauteing a jalapeno and an onion or a
shallot
added some frozen corn and then i just
cooked everything until the vegetables
didn't feel raw
i added a can of rinsed black beans and
then i seasoned it
mix it up with clean hands and make sure
to really crush the beans
add an egg and then my guilty pleasure
mexican blend shredded cheese
that's optional don't forget a bunch of
panko breadcrumbs so it all sticks
together
form your patties with your hands and
then put them back in your skillet
make sure they get really crispy on both
sides toast a brioche bun
and then add some spicy mayo top with
avocado and don't forget your lime and
salt
hi drew i'm seyran from legally
plant-based and i'm so excited to show
you how to make a delicious snack
using a norishi start by cutting the
nori sheet and then add your tofu katsu
add some sushi rice top it with some
roasted sesame seeds
add carrots cabbage and some sliced
avocado
add spicy mayo a slice of vegan cheddar
some more rice some ketchu sauce and
crispy onions
then just fold it clockwise
and there you have it hey drew it's
marlon shotland with urban bliss life
and today i'm going to show you how to
make these super easy
super tasty airfryer chicken wings
first lightly oil the inside of your air
fryer basket or airfryer trays with
vegetable oil or olive oil spray
next place the chicken wings in a bowl
and pat them dry
sprinkle arrowroot starch over the wings
to coat them evenly
you can also use cornstarch instead
season the wings with salt and pepper
then place them in a single layer in
your airfryer basket or airfryer trays
airfry at 380 degrees fahrenheit for 12
minutes
then flip over the wings increase the
heat to 400 degrees fahrenheit
and airfry them for another 12 minutes
these chicken wings
are perfectly crispy on the outside and
tender and juicy on the inside
so easy right hey drew it's the perfect
time of year to make julia child's booth
bourguignon let me show you how i make
it
first dry three pounds of beef chuck
well with paper towels and season
generously with salt and pepper
working in batches sear the meat on all
sides cut
thick slices of bacon into half inch
pieces
add two thinly sliced onions and cook
until browned and caramelized peel two
large carrots and parsnips and cut into
large pieces
add the vegetables season with salt and
pepper then add two tablespoons flour
and three tablespoons tomato paste
stir to coat and cook for about two
minutes add three cups of beef stock and
wine reserving a glass for dinner bring
to a simmer and add the brown meat a
bundle of thyme one pound of brown
mushrooms and some pearl onions
cook in a 325 degree oven for about two
hours
serve over some creamy mashed potatoes
and top with fresh parsley
cheers drew happy cooking hi drew thanks
for having me back
on the show today i'm going to show you
how to tackle steak
it's always better to season your steak
with salt ahead of time a few hours is
fine but overnight is ideal this will
allow the salt to penetrate all the way
through to the center of the steak set
this on a wire rack and place it in your
fridge
uncovered for airflow if you got an
instant pot they all come with this
little rack how do you know when your
pan is hot and with this hack you will
forever get a good sear on your steak
every single time drop a teaspoon of
water into your pan and when it looks
like team 1000 out of terminator it
means your pan is ready
this is called the leidenfrost effect
and if your water sticks and bubbles out
means your pan is too cold and it's not
ready
for new york strips i like to add zero
oil fat side down first
render out that fat and then sear both
sides for about two minutes per side
when you're ready to butter base turn
down the heat to low because butter
burns at high temperatures which can
leave
burnt bitter taste onto the steak and
butter absolutely loves aromatics like
thyme and garlic because they're good
buddies and they infuse
really really well together a digital
thermometer is a must
always remove the steak 10 degrees lower
than your desired doneness because the
steak will continue to cook even when
it's out of the pan cover and let it
rest
resting allows the muscle proteins to
relax so it can retain more of its own
juices
and flavor i like to make a quick sauce
using horseradish a mustard
salt and pepper i always cut my steaks
at a bias because it always makes for a
better
meat fan and finally don't sleep on the
resting juices
this is where the magic is at now watch
this move whoa
now you tell me if this will taste good
or not
and that's how you cook a steak wow i'm
in a delicious
food coma just for watching that
[Music]
you